This is not the first time this group has targeted us.
In recent years, they have bombed Yemeni government facilities and Western hotels,...
...restaurants and embassies, including our embassy in 2008, killing one American.
So as president, I've made it a priority to strengthen our partnership with the Yemeni government...
...training and equipping their security forces,...
...sharing intelligence and working with them to strike al-Qaeda terrorists.
And even before Christmas Day, we had seen the results.
Training camps have been struck, leaders eliminated, plots disrupted.
And all those involved in the attempted act of terrorism on Christmas must know,...
...you too will be held to account.
But these efforts are only part of a wider cause.
It's been nearly a year since I stood on the steps of the US Capitol...
...and took the oath of office as your president.
And with that oath came the solemn responsibility that I carry with me...
...every moment of every day,...
...the responsibility to protect the safety and security of the American people.
On that day, I also made it very clear,...
...our nation is at war against a far reaching network of violence and hatred,...
...and that we will do whatever it takes to defeat them and defend our country,...
...even as we uphold the values that have always distinguished America among nations.
Make no mistake; that's exactly what we've been doing.